ah qu'est-ce qu'on est serré on faut
deux siècles moustache tous les champs
du lycée des questions essentielles au
port de sète nos salaires des cardinaux
ont fait tourner les merguez jean pierre
françois présentation des survivants ont
dit un jour croisé villeneuve la civic
allez vous dirigez pas mis les cheveux
comme ça moi depuis
oui je sais il sort on ira faire la
burqa à prendre des sous pour les
cercles exactement oui d'accord ok alors
voulant attendre mon père il voulait les
2500 euros la place de sébastien envoyé
chirurgie lasik fincher la raquette je
tiens la balle non allez allez c'est bon
il va bouger c'est malik mali vous jouer
vraiment bien j'ai jugé bon vous jouez
pour sébastien faut l'avouer j'ai
pourtant au coeur à temps mais concentré
n'a pas augmenté 0
on est vraiment 010 non mais 1 0 on s'en
fout 00 tu as une programmation c'est
parti voilà ce qu'a dit comment l'homme
idéal pour une séquence nommé des halles
pour moi si tu as mélange de milan
disant oui pour le sourire oui
mokhtar déchets vaut bien
[Applaudissements]
et de toutes les élections c'est notre
terre battue voilà et la piscine pouvait
jouer je voudrais jouer avec votre cas
et rooney c'est votre match vous aimez
bonnet avec tout ce n'est pas tout
puisque je convoque à une bonne passe
comme ça ben ali imed dalet a découvert
m'emballer enfin qu'on soit en france
merci d'être là alors où il sera sur les
très heureux de voir nous avait donc été
élu donc c'était samedi soir même sur
tf1
les spots si on peut être sur place et
fait un petit peu de respect pour
l'histoire si vous perdez vous avez
envie de faire quoi après miss france
les papiers et charles la normale mandat
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
jean rendez vous à la préfecture une
arnaque 18
[Applaudissements]